bueno pues ya probamos que raíz de 2 es
un número irracional qué te parece si
ahora pensamos en probar en demostrar
que raíz de p es también un número
irracional si p es un número primo
entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí p es primo
ok p es un número primo y lo que quiero
probar es que raíz de pep es un nombre
racional y voy a utilizar algo muy
parecido a la demostración que hice
acerca de que de raíz de 2 es un número
irracional así que si no has visto el
vídeo de hacerlo no te lo pierdas porque
creo que vamos a utilizar cosas muy
parecidas p es primo y bueno vamos a ver
qué pasa con la raíz de b quiero
analizar qué va a pasar con la raíz de
pep si es irracional o racional y bueno
voy a seguir la misma idea que hice en
el vídeo pasado y por lo tanto voy a
suponer que raíz de pep es un número
racional y con esto voy a ver si puedo
llegar a un absurdo y si llega un
absurdo entonces tendré la demostración
por contradicción
no es un número racional entonces debe
de ser irracional pero bueno como voy a
demostrar que raíz de p es un número
irracional y lo voy a demostrar por
contradicción pues vamos a suponer lo
contrario vamos a suponer que raíz de p
es racional es racional y recuerda que
voy a suponer esto para llegar a la
contradicción ahora sí raíz de p es
racional entonces podemos decir que raíz
de p lo voy a poner con este color que
raíz de p lo podemos ver como a como a
entre b como a entre ven o que como una
fracción donde a esos números enteros
con una razón entre números enteros pero
de igual manera voy a pedir algo muy
importante de esta fracción que sea una
fracción irreducible que ya no se pueda
reducir más tú me vas a decir bueno es
que hay fracciones que se puedan reducir
si esta fracción se pudiera reducir
reducir a todo lo que se puede todo lo
que se puede
cuantos pasos sean necesarios hasta
obtener una fracción irreducible que ya
no se puede reducir más es decir que ahí
pe sean primos relativos entre sí o sean
como primos y por lo tanto esto de aquí
esto de aquí me va a dar una fracción
aunque no se puede reducir no
se puede no se puede reducir reducir y
de igual manera en la demostración que
raíz de 12 es irracional aquí está la
clave aquí algo importantísimo para
entender la demostración de que la raíz
de pep es irracional ok a / b no se
puede reducir y eso quiere decir que
tanto a como b no tienen factores en
común lo voy a poner aquí
y b&b
no tienen factores en común
tienen tienen factores en común factores
en común
excepto uno excepto
ok ahora ya que sé que hay b son primos
relativos entre sí y que esta fracción
no se puede reducir entonces voy a
utilizar un poco de manipulación
algebraica para decir que pepe lo
podemos escribir como a cuadrada aunque
hay donde el color de am a cuadrada ok
lo único que estoy haciendo se elevando
al cuadrado a ambos lados de esta
igualdad aquí el cuadrado con la raíz se
van y del otro lado me queda a cuadrada
entre b cuadrada entre b elevado al
cuadrado elevado al cuadrado y esto lo
escribo sí porque de igual manera como
vimos en el vídeo pasado de aquí voy a
despejar a cuadrada y entonces voy a
decir que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que poner que b cuadrada de cuadrada por
p
ok por pep y la p la voy a poner aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que a cuadrada que
a cuadrada lo único que hice fue
multiplicar por b cuadrada de ambos
lados de esta ecuación es decir que p x
de cuadrada es igual aa cuadrada ok y
eso de qué me sirve a porque aquí lo que
me está diciendo es que a a ver le voy a
poner así de aquí puedo concluir que a
cuadrada este de aquí es un múltiplo de
p es un
lown de penn y cómo podemos hacer eso
bueno se note desde aquí si yo tengo ap
multiplicado por un número entero y b
cuadrada es un número entero entonces
esto me da un múltiplo de p y si esto es
igual a cuadrada eso quiere decir que a
cuadrada es un múltiplo de p ok muy
parecido a lo que hicimos en el vídeo
pasado a cuadrada es un múltiplo de p ok
y entonces esto quiere decir que a es
múltiplo de p pues veamos imagínate que
yo tengo aquí a a haba de color salmón
entonces aquí voy a poner am y voy a
descomponer el factores primos a
entonces si yo pongo la descomposición
en factores primos de am supongamos que
es
y para no ponerle p de primo voy a
ponerle f
efe 1 es un primo efe 2 es otro primo a
efe 3 es otro primo y recuerda que todos
números lo podemos descomponer en
factores primos hasta llegar a fm todos
estos son números primos y es lo que
vale
a los efector izando en números primos
ahora como podríamos escribir a cuadrada
ya teniendo esto de aquí bueno pues a
cuadrada es exactamente lo mismo y
podría decir que esto es déjame copiar y
pegar para que no se haga tan largo todo
esto lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar
este a dos veces así que lo voy a poner
una vez por aquí ok y lo voy a poner
otra vez por aquí ok
vamos a ver si me cabe o no no me cabe
entonces lo que voy a hacer es mover un
poco este de aquí y vamos a moverlo ok
este de aquí lo voy a mover un poco
control x y ahora le voy a mover
un poco lo voy a mover para acá ok a
cuadrada lo puedo ver así estos
multiplicando a estos así que voy a
tomar a estos de aquí y los voy a mover
para acá ya perfecto ahora si me caben y
lo que estoy haciendo tomándome a
cuadrada y al cuadrado es el mismo que
ahora espera y por lo tanto es lo mismo
que estos que multiplican a su vez a
estos mismos y bueno inclusive lo
podríamos acomodar en la siguiente
manera podremos decir que al cuadrado es
exactamente lo mismo
ok que íbamos a acomodarlo así que f1 a
f1 por f1 ok por efe 2 por efe 2 ok
esta es una efe ok y a esto puntitos
vamos a multiplicarlo por todos demás y
después por efe n por efe
n ahora lo que quiero que veas es que
aquí dice justo aquí dice que a cuadrada
tiene como uno de los factores como uno
de todos estos primos apple si a
cuadrada lo podemos ver como p que
multiplica
entonces debe de ser alguno de todos
estos podría ser este de aquí o no se
esté de aquí o no se esté de aquí alguno
de todos estos tiene que ser
forzosamente penn porque a cuadrada lo
podemos ver de esta manera y p es un
número primo por lo tanto supongamos que
éste es pero digo no sé bien cuál sea el
valor este debe pero vamos a suponer que
éste es p si éste es p entonces f2
también es p
ok y de igual manera si es f1 o fn o f 3
el que tú quieras tomar si f 2 espera
entonces f 2 también la espe y eso
quiere decir que a am también tiene como
factor ap porque ésta f 2 y entonces
aquí justo es el momento en donde vamos
a poder concluir el ejemplo desde aquí
vamos a poder concluir que a es múltiplo
de p es múltiplo de p
y esto es importantísimo
a es múltiple p porque tiene como un
factor cuando descomponemos a en números
primos o dicho de otra manera podríamos
decir que vamos a ponerlo aquí
lo puedo ver como un cierto número le
voy a poner acá acá por pep por ver ok
si es múltiple entonces podemos ver a am
como que porten ok una vez que ya
tenemos que este es un posible valor
para am vamos a sustituir lo justo aquí
y vamos a hacer lo mismo que hicimos
cuando nosotros tomamos la raíz de 2 voy
a sustituir este de aquí aquí a ver que
me queda y me quedaría que ven por be
cuadrada ok donde el color debe aquí por
be cuadrada es exactamente lo mismo que
a cuadrada pero a cuadrada lo podemos
ver como kp elevado al cuadrado
aquí adentro voy a poner acá por b acá
por pep ok y bueno si yo llego al
cuadrado esto me va a quedar que eso es
exactamente
que p cuadrada porque a cuadrada que al
cuadrado por p cuadrada estoy
distribuyendo este cuadrado y de este
lado tengo a para volver cuadrada ap por
b cuadrada y de aquí que crees que voy a
hacer bueno pues lo que voy a hacer es
despejar ave cuadrada y para esto que te
pareces individuo todo entre p entonces
me va a quedar que b cuadrada me va a
quedar que me cuadrada lo podemos ver
como a cada cuadra da cal cuadrada por p
por p y esto porque estoy dirigiendo
todo entre p ok y con esto estoy
diciendo entonces con esto y déjeme
poner aquí una flecha para que nos
confundamos que ve cuadrada muy cuadrada
es múltiplo de p múltiplo de p y estoy
diciendo esto por la misma razón que a
cuadradas múltiplo de p porque podemos
escribir a cuadrada como un p por b
cuadrada y aquí ave cuadrada la podemos
escribir como k cuadrada por p y sirve
cuadrada es múltiplo de p eso quiere
decir
pero para arriba eso quiere decir que ve
es múltiplo múltiplo de d
y justo en este momento es donde cae la
contradicción no se puede que sea un
múltiplo de p y que psa múltiplo pp y
que ésta sea una fracción irreducible
porque precisamente habíamos dicho que a
y b no tienen factores en común excepto
el 1 y p no es 1 porque es un número
primo y acabamos de ver que tanto a como
ven tienen como factor ap y con esto
llegamos en la contradicción no puede
pasar que no tengan factores en común y
tengan como factor ap entonces es justo
en este momento donde ya podemos
concluir que la raíz de p no debe de ser
racional dejemos quitar esto de aquí no
debe de ser racional
la raíz de p debe de ser forzosamente
irracional
que es justo lo que queríamos probar si
nosotros llegamos a una contradicción
suponiendo que la raíz de perth es
racional entonces tendríamos que decir
que la raíz de p es irracional queda
justo al resultado al que queríamos
llegar de lugo